[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing a couple of things
the first is a much debated aspect of
harry potter
blood purity within this i'm going to be
looking at the blood purity
spectrum and what is required for
someone to be considered
a half blood i'm also going to be
discussing voldemort
and infamous german dictator adolf
hitler
drawing parallels between them blood
status is one of the most controversial
aspects of the wizarding world
a concept in which wizarding families
can be distinguished by the level of
magically endowed family members
generally speaking
people are slotted into one of the
following categories
pure blood half blood or muggle the
existence of such a system
however certainly isn't a positive thing
the different classifications of blood
purity
in the wisdom world actually act in a
very similar fashion
to race in the real world which
obviously leaves the door open
for things like prejudice the wizarding
world is certainly not shy to elements
of prejudice
in fact one of the main focuses of
voldemort's death eaters
was establishing power over the worlds
of half-bloods and muggles
voldemort felt that those with pure
bloodlines deserve to be in power
and anyone who got ins away would either
be murdered or made to be
indefinitely subservient a slave to his
regime
of course after enough time in power
it's also likely that the pure
bloodlines
which are presently on their way out
would be able to make a resurgence
of course it shouldn't be a surprise to
anyone that parallels can be drawn
between voldemort
and the death eaters with hitler and the
nazis during world war ii
i wanted harry to leave our world and
find exactly the same problems in the
wizarding world
so you have the intent to impose a
hierarchy you have bigotry
and this notion of purity which is this
great fallacy
but it crops up all over the world
people like to think themselves superior
and that if they can pride themselves in
nothing else they can pride themselves
on perceived purity
so yeah that follows a parallel to
nazism that quote was from jk rowling
the nazis were of course infamous for
the persecution of jewish people
among other minorities basically anyone
was persecuted
that didn't fit into hitler's perceived
notion of the aryan
master race the master race is a concept
in nazi ideology
in which the putative nordic or aryan
races predominant among germans and
other northern european peoples
are deemed the highest in racial
hierarchy members of this alleged master
race
were referred to as haran mention master
humans in this instance aryans were the
pure bloods
and any other group could be placed into
either the half blood or
muggle category in 1925 hitler published
mein kampf
an autobiographical manifesto that
outlined his political ideologies
and anti-semitic perspective in his book
hitler wrote of his hatred towards what
he believed
to be the world's twin evils namely
communism and
judaism he said that his aim was to
eradicate both from germany
and moreover stress his intention to
unite all germans in the process of
destroying them
does that sound like someone else to you
where hitler rallied the nazis
voldemort rallied the death eaters and
where hitler's sort to eradicate
non-aryans voldemort sought to enslave
and dominate
non-pure bloods one thing that i want to
quickly explore before diving into this
further is
what constitutes a half blood in an
interview
jk rowling was asked a similar question
why are some people in the wizarding
world
called half blood even though both their
parents were magical
the expressions pureblood half-blood and
muggle-born
have been coined by people to whom these
distinctions matter and express
their originators prejudices as far as
somebody like lucius malfoy is concerned
for instance a muggleborn is as bad as a
muggle
therefore harry would be considered only
half wizard because of his mother's
grandparents
if you think this is far-fetched look at
some of the real charts the nazis used
to show
what constituted aryan or jewish blood i
saw one in the holocaust museum in
washington
when i had already devised the pure
blood half-blood and muggle-born
definitions
and was chilled to see that the nazis
used precisely the same warped logic
as the death eaters a single jewish
grandparent
polluted the blood according to their
propaganda
from this we can derive that the death
eaters used similar methodology to the
nazis
suggesting that similar third reich
formula rules were in effect
in germany itself the anun pass and
nuremberg
laws classified people as jews if they
descended from three
or four jewish grandparents a person
with one or two jewish grandparents
was a michelin a crossbreed of mixed
blood
however one other important distinction
to make is that
like with any oppressive regime the
bosses make the rules
we see this with lord voldemort who
ironically was a half-blood himself
while actively leading a regime that
sought to enslave anyone that wasn't
a pure blood we also saw this with the
nazis
as they notably issued a german blood
certificate
to erhad milch a jewish-born field
officer that oversaw the development of
the luftwaffe
after erhard was issued his certificate
hermann goring
famously said where you de ist beshte
which means i decide who is a jew this
kind of behavior is completely
irrational
and makes absolutely no sense but then
again
these regimes don't make any sense these
types of movements
are largely based on irrational fear a
thirst for power
and an incredible amount of hypocrisy
one thing important to note
however is that hitler and voldemort
didn't only share similar goals
they were actually quite similar people
in a lot of other ways
let's take a look at just how similar
they were it appears that from as early
as childhood
with voldemort and hitler exhibited
signs of a manipulative
persuasive personality a personality
that closely followed them into
adulthood
and largely contributed to their
eventual successes
in achieving power voldemort aka tom
riddle
was a highly manipulative young boy it
was dangerously paired with a high iq
a combination which meant that he was
always able to convince others
to give him what he wanted while still
very young voldemort became
entirely self-aware of his talents and
would use emotional warfare on adults
and fellow orphans alike
hitler showed similar characteristics as
a boy and though he didn't grow up in an
orphanage
there is evidence to support that he was
able to manipulate his mother
into pampering him both boys would play
off of the emotions of others
but also tread carefully when they were
confronted with someone
that they could clearly not manipulate
their uncanny ability to recognize
individuals
that they wouldn't be able to manipulate
is likely a product of their high levels
of charisma
for example tom riddle played the role
of good little orphan boy
when dumbledore came to visit and
similarly hitler never tried any of his
emotional warfare on his father
as he knew it would have been a futile
another dangerous trait that both men
exhibited was the ability to persuade
people specifically the ability
to convince others of their good
intentions tom riddle infamously
persuaded professor hora slughorn
to provide him with information on
horcruxes a classic example of
voldemort's manipulation
to horus tom was a good student with a
good head on his shoulders
he couldn't imagine what harm giving
that information to tom could have done
but that's exactly how tom wanted to
come across he knew exactly what he was
doing
he was able to come across in such a way
that even the exchange of information
pertaining to the worst forms of dark
magic wasn't something that slughorn
would deny him
in a similar case of persuasion hitler
at the age of 22
was able to convince his aunt to give
him a large amount of money
and leave him the bulk of her life's
savings money that i'm sure would have
normally been left
to others there is so much power in the
ability to convince people of things
and when you combine this skill with
unusual perceptions of the world
dangerous things can happen for
voldemort it meant amassing the legion
of death eaters to enslave half-bloods
and muggles
and for hitler it meant shifting the
perspective of an entire nation
creating an anti-semitic intolerant
environment
where his master race would reign
supreme both men were able to amass
large followings playing off of people's
deepest emotions
in order to get them on board with their
regimes in order for hitler to come to
power
he played off of weaknesses that germany
had like the level of poverty
and powerlessness that they likely felt
as a nation
he brought these things to the forefront
of people's minds introducing himself
as the solution voldemort used fear to
amass his followers
he was a known powerful figure so
powerful in fact that not a single one
of his death eaters ever dared question
his half-blood status a prime example of
this is lucius malfoy
who would follow anything that the
darkhold said mainly out of pure fear
i could go on for ages making
comparisons between these two figures
even going as far as to analyze the
symbolism used by each man's regime
voldemort the dark mark for hitler the
swastika
but i think you get the gist of it if
you have any questions pertaining to the
topic of today's video
i'd love to hear them so leave a comment
down below i may expand on this topic
further if there is enough interest
until next time remember you place too
much importance
and you always have done on the
so-called purity of blood
you fail to recognize that it matters
not what someone is born
but what they grow to be
[Music]